with food rations from the U.N food
agency been cut many in this Camp fear
they'll soon go hungry cramped in a
makeshift tent with nine other family
members
misses our home in Myanmar she left
everything behind during a Crackdown by
the military
right now we are facing difficulties in
getting adequate amount of rations
sometimes we have to buy items from
outside with whatever savings we have
back home our family were farmers so it
was much easier to manage our life
unlike here
frequent incidents of fire violence and
threat of flood and Landslide during
monsoon season makes life challenging
here for rohingya
pod living here
on with the
limelage family like ours
many rohingya said they were used to
receiving different types of food Aid
during Ramadan in previous year but that
stopped expert thinks the Russian's been
provided are insufficient and any
further decrease the post-grave health
problems for the rohingya it is
the recent cut in rations is worrying
people as most don't have any other
income Source here in the mosque we
don't even have a Nifty meal arrangement
for the community unlike in the rehein
state
um
Bangladesh hosts more than a million
drawing of Muslims but its government is
gradually losing patience with the
International Community saying it's
failing to help resolve the crisis
all the month of Ramadan most rohingya
refugees say they are thankful that they
are safe here but their light still
remain a daily struggle amid all the
trauma and tribulation most still dream
of returning home one day
Al Jazeera Cox's Bazaar